one of the top front office executives
in her time the NFL now with CBS Sports
joining me here with Amy Trask how are
you Amy I'm well and I thank you for
having me I let the cat out of the bag
this morning on Twitter rich I've been
such a fan of yours for so long I won't
say how long so thanks for having well I
got to tell you though Amy you and I
first met many NFL League meetings ago
and when you and Al Davis walked in the
room there was a certain level of
attention paid that we had no idea what
was going to go away and I was one of
the first NFL Network employees to go up
to you and just chat with you and it was
always fun to watch you and al maneuver
in an NFL meeting I'll tell you that you
do you just described that very very
gracefully and gently bouncing we did
make a bit of a ruckus before I'll
abstain on everything before he pretty
much did he ever vote us on anything he
always abstained Amy always happy you
know what that is one of my proudest
accomplishments I got him to stop
abstaining and the way I got him to stop
abstaining was yeah when they asked for
the vote I simply voted before he could
have spin around the room and I would
either say yes or no and he would start
to abstain and I discussed that with him
a lot I just do it look there were times
for legal reasons we were advised by
counsel we had to abstain but he took it
to an art form and it drove me nuts and
I proudly someday that will be my
epitaph
I got us to stop it I remember that I
remember that Alice remember also and I
don't know if it's still this way
because it's been a while since I've
been to a League meeting that the tables
the way it was said it was just like a
big e where like the the the legs of the
e would come out from the you know the
long I guess stripe that connects the
legs of the e where all the executives
and the Commissioner would sit on that
spot and the NFL owners would sit on the
legs and I would always sit at the end
of the bottom of the e in that seat
every single time and he would just sit
there and then never raise his head when
it came to
and you know what rich two things
quickly in that regard number one it
always amazed me it was like something
out of a junior high school lunchroom
because everybody had to take the same
sneak every time I always thought it
would be a great idea if the rule was
you had to sit with different people
every meeting I thought it would have
just generated more conversation I will
tell you one last thing abstention sure
when I finally got him to stop and
staining a number of team owners and
executives said to me way to go way to
go and then we started voting no on
everything and I said bet you wish we
were still upstaged a me Trask here on
the Rich Eisen show now CBS sports
football analyst and kind guest here on
the Rich Eisen show let's get to it you
your first reaction hearing about the
NFL announcing they were holding a
Kaepernick workout in Atlanta this
Saturday was what a me oh it was a mixed
reaction hopeful of course that it was a
sincere well intended effort on the
league's part hopeful that it will be
received as such very very puzzled as to
why it would be on such short notice
in other words I don't know whether it
was for well intended reasons or whether
it was for PR reasons but either way to
do it on three days notice puzzled me
you know we're only finding out now
who's going to be in charge of the place
selection and getting receivers there
and how do you get good quality
receivers they're on three days notice
the logistics are really puzzling to me
if you're going to do something like
this and if we want to assume that it is
for well intended reasons not simply PR
again noting that I don't know the
reason why would you only do three days
notice that made no sense to me well
especially if it is only for PR right
then what that that makes zero sense and
then obviously if it's not for PR and it
we have to you know let's assume that's
what it is because why else would you
have this it's it just came out of
the blue I mean so the way it's being
run doesn't doesn't make much sense on
either level Amy I'm wondering what
you've been able to suss out or what you
can guess based on your your vast
history or knowledge of the way the
league operates well you make a great
point of course which is that if this
was for PR you're not getting a good
grade because if the goal of this was to
quiet the story down put an end of the
story it has the reverse effect now
there's a whole new storyline as to why
are you doing it in this manner you know
there's a famous ism if you will
Hamlin's raiser suggests that when you
can assume that something is done for
malicious or mendacious reasons or you
can assume there's simply some
incompetence of involved it generally is
the latter in other words Halen's raiser
tells us don't assume the worst don't
assume things are done for malicious
reasons assume they're simply done
poorly and that also is the discussion I
had for 30 years without when anytime
the league would do anything he would
immediately go DEFCON 5 you know and it
was just you know what's that expression
from the mob movies on to the mattresses
I actually learned that from I don't
know you've got mail to the mattresses
well that's what he would want to do and
I would say to him whoa whoa whoa let's
not assume this is being done for
malicious reasons let's just assume it's
being poorly done and I don't know which
is the case in this rich but I do know
that you're absolutely right if the goal
was to quiet things down it's hard to
reverse effect well let's let's take it
from the more I guess glass half-full
view point Amy Trask
here on the Rich Eisen show and that
this is well sure because you know the
the benefit of this can be that
executives do or Scouts do see
Kaepernick in person and the interview
process can somehow bridge whatever
divide an owner that thinks you know
what we can
use someone of his capabilities but I'm
concerned about how he would affect the
locker room and my community based on
the stances or sitting that or kneeling
he would take that that gets devote that
bridge gets divided through the
interview process that's part of
Saturday
let's just hope okay let's take that now
the issue though of scrambling the Jets
to get somebody to this event of note
that you are indicating we're taking
this seriously how would you as a front
office executive let's just say you and
have an owner and you are of a mindset
of like I want to handle this I want to
see this in person or I want to see have
somebody of note what logistical issues
are there to be told about it just a
couple of days in advance in a week 11
of an NFL season well you hit the
proverbial nail on the head rich and
it's not whether or not you can get
someone there
absolutely positively any team that
wishes to have someone in Atlanta on
Saturday can do that it's just not that
hard the question is who can you get to
Atlanta because unless you're on a bye
week and and if you're on a bye it may
be trouble scrambling to get people who
are taking a couple of days off and
maybe somewhere unreachable which does
happen rarely but occasionally it's just
if you're not on a bye you're not gonna
get in with coach you're probably not
going to get a GM you may not and again
if you're proximate to Atlanta if you're
playing close by if you're an hour
flight away if you're assigned to scout
a game that's an hour flight away that's
one thing but if you're across the
country or you're a good distance away
and your Scouts are at games and you're
getting ready to go on a road trip or
you've got a home game you are not going
to get a very very senior person but can
you get someone absolutely positively
yes and then what happens what happens
with the information what what like
let's just say your team is playing a
week 11 not proximate to Atlanta
and your HC or you're in a bye week in
the HC or the general manager of already
made plans to be in like Bermuda because
they knew their bye week would be right
here and it's a 10-week slog to get to
that spot I don't know I'm just throwing
stuff out there what do you do with the
information how do you take it in and
actually use it to your benefit to maybe
higher calling company well that's going
to be teen specific and every team does
this differently and that's not an
effort on my part to equivocate or to
use a football term to punt but it's an
organization think highly of those that
it deploys to evaluate situations and if
an organization takes input from those
it sends around the country to gather
information well then you're going to
listen if an organization sends a scout
or someone from the personnel department
even if that person is junior level if
that person comes back and says okay I
asked all the questions that we
discussed ahead of time that you wanted
me to ask here's the answers I got
here's the impression I had different
team ownership and different team
executives are going to rely upon it's
junior staff differently than others
one thing teams should do is sending
someone who's junior on staff arm them
with all the data you want them to
collect this is what we want you to ask
Colin this is what we want you to
observe and then when that person comes
back listen to what he or she has to say
what about you Amy if from somebody from
your perspective is a front office
executive let's just say you don't have
a need for colin kaepernick at
quarterback but support his desire to
play in the NFL and the fact that he
should have a spot here would you attend
something like this just for that reason
alone I would attend for any number of
reasons that would be one of them but no
one knows when one might have a need for
a quarterback you know there are a lot
of teams you know I don't think the
Steelers knew going into the game and
which Ben Roethlisberger was injured
that they would be starting Mason
Rudolph for the rest of the season and
we could go on and on and on through the
list there are teams which need
quarterbacks every single team is one
snap away from needing a quarterback
so yes I would send someone for the
reason you identified but I would also
send someone for football reasons and
then what what goes on in a front office
where somebody might sit around and say
you know what this is just a problem
with our fan base or I'm afraid of a
problem of our fan bases there's some
sort of work that can be done locally
just polling of something along those
lines to try and get from all that yeah
this is what I suggested at the outset
of this issue you know we live in a time
right now where everybody is treating
things as binary and it's yes or it's no
or its upper it's down when things need
not be binary what I would do is I would
hold a proverbial town hall and I would
do it in the largest place possible I
would do it in a theater or I would do
it in a concert venue or I would do it
in a stadium and I would invite ticket
holders and fans and I would say let's
have a discussion about this and let's
use this as a moment in society to learn
how to exchange thoughts in a reasoned
and reasonable manner and you know what
we are not all going to agree about this
and that's okay but we have to learn as
a society how to disagree agreeably so I
would turn what many teens are looking
at as a negative into a positive which
is how do I use this moment in time to
embrace our entire fan base and say
let's lead the way in showing people how
to disagree agreeably I would also bring
in member armed forces both people who
have served people who are serving so
many of whom have articulated stop
throwing out that this is disrespectful
to the flag or the troops because I
enlisted to defend the right of others
to say and to do that which I disagree
that's one of our greatest freedoms so I
would use this moment in time to try to
change the way we address disagreement
we Trask here on the Rich Eisen show
before I let you go 17 games season
being thrown out there is called unquote
increasingly likely Richard Sherman
who is in on a lot of these negotiations
representing players with the Players
Association called that report tactics
from a league using their media
collection connections to push a false
story we aren't even close to a deal
they are literally pushing out their
proposal is something we agree with
which is ridiculous
he said that in response to Eric Weddle
who on Twitter from the rams said if we
agree to 17 games scheduled it would be
a travesty not sure why it's even on the
table what's your assessment of all of
this Amy well we're in the midst of
negotiations and different parties
handle negotiations differently and I
think we need to assume that everything
that everyone involves says is in some
regards part of that negotiation I'm
intrigued with the 17 game schedule but
only with these caveats one it would
have to come with a reduction in the
preseason and two it would have to come
with a significant not a man or two but
a significant increase in roster side
and that's for health and safety reasons
among other things so if you want to
talk to me a player rep about increasing
the number of games I want to increase
the roster by a significant amount I
want to reduce preseason games and oh by
the way if we're going to increase the
roster I want a little more money to
take care of those divisions Amy you are
the best I follow you on twitter at Amy
Trask I love your attitude on that
website and obviously your work with CBS
Sports is must-see and always enjoy our
chats immensely but you knew that and I
always enjoy joining you I am a big fan
of here right back at Jamie Trask it's
called mutual admiration at hey me Trask
on Twitter it she is a must follow for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app